what's going on reject nation we're
going to watch today from our buddy
warren from cosmic wonder mephisto
revealed in one division poster the
fisto easter eggs
in one division warren's been branching
out and doing a lot more of these theory
breakdown videos
i've been very much impressed so i was
like all right the next one we gotta do
because he's been right about quite a
few things so far
let's get into action people
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and where recently we've been
looking for
and into every single possible clue and
hint that we can find in one division to
figure out just
who is behind everything that is
happening in the one division series on
disney plus
now there are many different theories
out there of course i have
all of them involving this video let's
look at what marvel is actually giving
us
what they're trying to hint to us and
what they're trying to actually tell us
in these small little details and easter
eggs because
after all like dottie tells us in one
division the devil
is in the details and that's what we're
going to break down today
the details let's go if marvel tells
us the devil is in the details then
maybe they're actually
literally telling us that the devil
mephisto is in the details
after all marvel stuff the little
details with super awesome easter eggs
so we should be breaking down the little
details like
we always do of course i do wonder to
myself
when marvel did have that line in there
the devils of the details
if they knew that everyone would be
running with that line
going is the devil in the d is that
mephisto they
must have thought that they literally
have me down to this point where i'm
like it's either definitely mephisto or
they really want us to
think that's doing it definitely not
let's take a look
at other possible hints and possible
easter eggs for this big red horn guy
let's start off with a new one division
poster that marvel studios released
yesterday because since it's been
released everybody has been talking
about it because
since it came out yesterday fans have
been doing what we do best
looking at those extremely tiny details
and some fans think that they have
spotted the devil himself
mephisto right in the middle of the
poster if you take a look
right above wanda's head between vision
and agnes's head
we can see a wallpaper background and
right in the middle of all their heads
on this background is what some people
believe to be
mephisto and if we zoom in on it it
definitely
does kind of look like a devil with
horns but
is it mephisto it certainly does look
like it but
does it just look like it because we're
looking for it would marvel really put
this so
in our face i wouldn't put it past them
plus it is in a very coincidental and
convenient spot
right next to agatha harkness i mean
agnes
but it is very coincidental that it is
right next to agnes the person that we
believe to be agatha hartness and who we
believe to be working for the devil
himself mephisto but let's take a look
at some more concrete evidence
hexagons these things are everywhere and
yes we have been talking about them
but now there's just some new evidence
that we can't avoid talking about
and a possible hint at yet another
villain who could be in the wanda vision
series who is right in front of our
faces
now when we all first started theorizing
about hexagons i took a step back and
thought well
are we just finding them because again
we're looking for them
but we know that marvel does everything
you know i just realized
warren
this shape's a hexagon i haven't even
thought of it
i hadn't even thought of it the devil's
in the details
after all if marvel is mimicking and
recreating old sitcoms in one division
why did they change the brady bunch
intro from squares to hexagons
why not just keep them squares and why a
copyrighted one
did the frame around juan envision
become a hexagon
we are an unusual couple you know oh i
don't think that was ever in question
now we could have shrugged these off but
then marvel slapped us in the face with
it in episode four
in episode four sword discovered a
energy
barrier bubble perimeter whatever you
would like to call it
around west view and this energy barrier
that wanda's magic
or someone else's magic has set up is in
the shape of a hexagon now
that is not coincidental that is done
entirely on paper
hexagons yeah how hexagons are type of
symbol for
aim but i'm pretty sure aim isn't
responsible for this energy field
the reason is i doubt aim has the
technology to magically change someone's
clothes and appearance once they go
through this energy
this has to be magic it has to be the
work of wanda or somebody else who uses
powerful magic
hold on a second i do have a theory of
how aim could be
actually responsible for the hexagon
shape we do
set up aim in iron man 3. king the
conqueror
had connections to aim kang is supposed
to be
in ant-man 3 the quantum movie so
i could see a scenario here where if
they're setting up
king the conqueror and if he is
associated with aim to some degree then
maybe
kang is probably involved in this in
some way that's just a little theory of
mine that i feel like no one's going
with but i don't feel
that wrong without that [ __ ] then you'll
be able to cut back to this when you're
right
this is also something that agent wu
picked up on as well
he noticed that the perimeter was a
hexagon and on his whiteboard
he even wrote why hexagonal shape so
clearly this has some specific
meaning to whatever is happening in juan
domination it's a common shape of course
as many of you know by now a lot of
people
are comparing the hexagon shape to
mephisto because it has six
corners and of course 666 is the sign of
the devil and in the mcu the devil is
mephisto
the ruler of the hell realm but there's
also another
jesus between hexagons and satan that i
haven't really heard anybody else talk
about
and that is a connection that they both
share and that is the planet
saturn now this would be an extremely
detailed and thought
out connection but i would not put it
past that's not marvel
due to the greek mythology universe and
ant-man and the wasp
that continuity is insane and only
marvel studios can really think of stuff
like that
the planet saturn actually has a hexagon
on it
scientists discovered this in 1981 and
you can see very clear pictures of it
now what's really interesting here is
that saturn is actually
associated with satan and some people
actually believe that satan
is saturn but the bottom line is there's
a connection between hexagons and saturn
and saturn and the devil
now of course this could be absolutely
nothing at all and we could just be
reaching and hoping for theories to come
true
i don't think so man i think i think i'm
hoping that's the case
where nick fury was flying to on the
ship was to saturn saturn satan saturn
hexagon
before i hope that's it man nasa helping
out with some viral markings i would
love it
i would love it the hexagons and why the
devil easter eggs why say the devils in
the details and then agnes who we
believe to be agatha hartness say that's
not the only place he's in
now as i mentioned marvel could battle
hinting at another
possible villain in the one division
series one that oh sorry keep pausing
your video with the fact that we are
going
more cosmic if you do link the
supernatural side
of mephisto because that's the things
you got the sci-fi elements of the
cosmic then you got the supernatural
side with characters like
ghost rider blade so if you're linking
your cosmic world with your supernatural
world more clearly in your movies
maybe the sadder thing works please it
would be an
interesting cool way to work in actual
history to the lore like they are
showing they want to do with stuff like
loki too exactly man
so i mean it's probably not the case but
another possible villain in the one
division series one that many people may
not expect
and again it's leaning on the hexagon
theory but not necessarily stating that
the hexagon means mephisto
in the beginning of one division episode
four we are introduced to tyler hayward
or
director hayward no one's trusted this
guy
no i don't monica rambo go to sword's
headquarters and go into tyler hayward's
office
and some people have pointed out that
his pictures are lined up
oh even his carpet some people have also
pointed out that his carpet has hexagons
now if there is truly a connection here
this is very very interesting because
that would mean there are hexagons
within this bubble reality that wanda
and vision are in
and the outside world but not just in
the outside
real world in the real world in
someone's office who has a
lot of power this could hint that
director but also
hexagons are just shapes and everything
that is going on
now there are some theories out there
that say he is mephisto himself however
i don't really think that's the case
it just doesn't seem to line up to me
however director hayward could be a
villain in disguise
after this is i think that's the case i
am kind of getting alexander pierce
vibes from him
alexander pierce was in captain america
the winter soldier he was portrayed to
be one of the good guys being a part of
the united states government
shield and the world security council
paul newman did such a good job
under cover confirmed that shield at
some point
moves to sword sword and shield are kind
of the same thing at this point
and if hydra at one point could
infiltrate shield it wouldn't be
too far-fetched to think that another
enemy could infiltrate
sword especially with the scrolls
introduced into the mcu now which is
also a suspicion of jimmy woo because he
wrote scrolls on the whiteboard as well
i think uh marvel's at the point now
where they're just like stop building
government
no more agencies are all going to have
an evil dude at the head at some point
it's not going to get compromised
there's no point could he be working
for mephisto could he be mephisto
himself according to some theories he
could be
could he be working for aim and somehow
aim is involved in all of this
there is no doubt that these hexagons
mean something that is very clear now
marvel has made that clear the real
question is now are we actually finding
real hexagons that are connected or are
we simply reaching
it does seem like we have discovered
quite a few easter eggs and hints at
mephisto within the one division series
but
what do you think about all of these
different easter eggs that we found i
mean be sure to let me know in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news about wannavision and
other
mcu content for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram
now every time
[Laughter]
look guys all right there was a time
where i would say
that the hexagon shape is reaching but
it's at the point now where i i really
don't
think it is especially with the fact
that jimmy wu is the first question is
why hexagonal shapes so the hexagonal
shapes are obviously
very intentional it's like the same
thing can be said for the poster like
are you reaching
for that poster um maybe
if it comes out that it is mephisto
officially then i go
all right it was in that poster the
whole time you know
if it's not mephisto then i'm like you
guys we're just reaching this is one of
the cases we've landed ourselves in
and i feel like it's not all so
unreasonable to assume that maybe
you know somebody needs to be watching
this from the outside as well as the
inside too on the hayward sides
yeah he's a bad guy he deal with it he's
patrick morgan from
freaking wonder woman he's alexander
pierce he's the mall warren i thought
you did a great job on this video though
i thought it was really wonderfully put
together and i love that you're
branching out and doing more of these
breakdown vids i think they're so fun to
talk about
guys subscribe because i wonder if you
haven't done so already click that
notification bell hit that like button
for us as well
last but not least
got a shout out my good friend michael b
omni
media he's been covering a lot of tv
shows on his channel wandavision being
one of them as well in my notification
bells he's undoubtedly the first one to
get them up which is kind of crazy to me
because in his time
they don't premiere until 3 a.m eastern
time so that means
he's up till 3 a.m to record his
reaction to this and that he's chopping
away
right away 99 of the time the same thing
with mandalorian
his reactions brought first he put out
this amazing godzilla versus kong theory
video where this guy
really demonstrates how much he knows
about
the godzilla monster verse like the
whole lord it's pretty crazy if you
haven't subscribed to his channel yet do
yourself a favor and check him out
especially if you're a fan of one of
vision or almost
anything related that one that woman is
the one guy watching
that woman so guys give him a follow
much love team michael appreciate all
the help you've been to us so far
catch you guys soon